ذا عنك هشام زقوت وما تابعته ورصدته من
تطورات منذ تركناك قبل
ساعه القصف الاسرائيلي مازال مستمرا وربما
تشاهدين الان هذه الجثامين من قبل هذه
الجثامين هي من جراء القصف الاسرائيلي فجر
هذا اليوم ومساء امس والقصف مازال مستمرا
في المناطق الشرقيه لدير البلح وسط قطاع
غزه القصف مازال مستمرا ربما تستمعين الى
اصوات الانفجارات هذه الناجمه عن قصف
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والمدفعيه
الاسرائيليه المتمركزه في المناطق الشرقيه
لقطاع غزه تستهدف تلك المناطق سواء
السكنيه او حتى وسط هذه المدن لكن حتى
الان ما يصل من معلومات هي المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه تركز قصفها للمناطق الجنوبيه
لا سما مناطق شرق مدينه خان يونس بن سهيلا
وخزاعه والقرار وعباس وهذه المناطق تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف بالاضافه الى محاص صرتها من
قبل قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا القصف
المدفعي مازال مستمرا على المناطق الشرقيه
لمخيم البريج لا سما منطقه جحر الديك التي
تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه
ويمكن لهذا القصف الاسرائيلي تبرير بان
هناك عده عمليات وعده استهدافات من قبل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه نفذتها في تلك
المناطق وبالتالي المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
تكثف من قصفها على ما يبدو لهذه المناطق
بعد هذه العمليات العسكريه التي نفذتها
المقاومه الفلسطينيه منطقه شرق البريج هي
باتت منطقه معزوله عن كافه مناطق وسط قطاع
غزه في ظل هذا الاستهداف المباشر حتى ان
سيارات الاسعاف لا تستطيع الوصول اليها
لكن الاصعب من كل ذلك ان من يستشهد هنا في
وسط قطاع غزه على الاقل لا يستطيع اصلا
ايجاد قبر له ف كما ترين هذه اعداد من
الشهداء وفي ثلاجه الموتى وفي خيمه الموتى
هناك مزيد من اعداد الشهداء الذين سقطوا
جراء الاستهداف المباشر من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لعده منازل سواء في
مخيم البريج في مخيم النصيرات وفي دير
البلح وسط قطاع غزه وهذه
الجثامين تظل على الارض لعده ساعات
والاقارب والاهل يبحثون عن وسع او متسع
لدفنهم في مقابر الشهداء لكن مقابر
الشهداء في وسط قطاع غزه باتت ممتلئه حتى
عمليات نقل الشهداء من هنا الى المقبره
اصلا تواجه صعوبه للغايه لا سما في ظل
النقص الحاد في الوقود وبالتالي لا يوجد
سيارات لا سما كانت تنقل هذه الجثامين في
سيارات اسعاف وبالتالي سيارات الاسعاف
اغلبها الان منشغل في جلب اصابات واجلاء
المصابين من مناطق مختلفه وبالتالي لا
يستطيعون نقل هذه الجثامين الى المقابر
والسيارات المدنيه لا يتوفر لديها وقود
وبالتالي هناك صعوبه حتى في نقل هذه الجتا
امين من المستشفى الى المقابر اذا وجدوا
قبرا فالمقابر باتت
ممتلئه الازقه الممرات كلها باتت حفرت
فيها المقابر حتى ان بعض الاراضي الموجوده
بجانب هذه المقابر باتت ممتلئه لان
الشهداء كثر وبالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي ما
زال مركزا على دير البلح على المناطق
الشرقيه على المناطق الشرقيه ايضا لخان
يونس والمناطق الشرقيه لرفح وقصفت
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ايضا عده
منازل في مدينه رفح وهذه المنطقه مدينه
رفع عندما نتحدث عنها فنحن نتحدث عن منطقه
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي للمواطنين
الفلسطينيين واعلن عده مرات انها مناطق
امنه ويتوجه الناس اليها حتى ان الناس
باتوا في الشوارع ونصبوا خياما هناك لكن
الجيش الاسرائيلي يكثف من قصفه ما بين
الفينه والاخرى لمدينه رفح ويستهدف في جل
هذا القصف منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه يدمرها
ويسويها بالارض على رؤوس السكان والنازحين
الذين بداخلها والذين هربوا من حمم القصف
الاسرائيلي في مناطق مختلفه فلجوا الى رفح
ولكن يلاحقهم القصف هناك وبالتالي القصف
ما زال مستمرا وهذا ينعكس بكل تاكيد على
هذه المستشفيات في وسط وجنوب
القطاع مستشفى كمستشفى شهداء الاقصى بكل
تاكيد هو مستشفى صغير ولا يستطيع تحمل هذا
العدد الكبير من الاصابات التي تصل يوميا
وهذه الاعداد الكبيره من الشهداء هشام
زقوت من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح